Jeremy collected AKA boffin Busta is a
16 year old from pond inlet nunavut he's
the new and an aspiring MC but when he
took the stage at his first-ever rap
concert in attalla with this year Jeremy
forgot his words
I'd be more but in a neutral but I
usually go English more when I tried to
do my life but alas fill them but
Jeremy's not alone a lot of kids in the
Arctic are losing their words these days
and just like Jeremy they're losing them
in an octa toot roughly 150,000 Inuit
live across the circumpolar north they
live in Alaska Canada Greenland and
Russia but in most communities fewer and
fewer young people are speaking the
Inuit language in Canada the language is
commonly referred to as an aptitude in
nunavut canada the inuit may make up
over three quarters of the population
but in many places Inuktitut still seems
like an afterthought the state of
inductive language is not like great but
when you go to an essential c'mere like
you cover the capital city you'll notice
that english is the language has spoken
everywhere and very few ineptitude being
spoken particularly among the younger
and younger and younger children so it
is it is a serious concern to us the
reasons for ineptitudes decline in
canada and other areas of the north are
complex for much of the 20th century
government policy in many regions of the
Arctic was to assimilate the Inuit into
Western culture use of a nuke titude was
often discouraged Inuktitut language
instructors are now scarce and Western
culture from the self still dominates
most regions of the Arctic
but some Inuit politicians and language
experts are pointing to another reason
for a nuke titude struggle to survive
there's just too many different dialects
because in up to two dialects don't just
differ from region to region in the
circumpolar North Inuktitut differs from
community to community there's different
pronunciations what didn't you took a
human doctor I know I'm it sucks
actually now it's different expressions
yeah and different writing systems that
means Inuit from different regions often
must use English to speak to each other
at a recent meeting of Inuit from Alaska
Canada and Greenland even the army of
professional in dicta to translators had
trouble keeping up with all the dialects
I see top quark hey Donovan geek and
Omiya also my grandparents ya ass luck
bad luck so it's an understanding around
Black Hawk i love what i see em licked
up no rule many language experts say
that needs to change they want to create
a standard Inuit language writing system
and eventually a standard ineptitude
dialect that could be used and
understood by Inuit all across the
Arctic Josie Cuza gak is a prominent
Inuit leader from rankin inlet nunavut
and a former school teacher I can were
in that state where people are actually
thinking about well you know it's about
time that we go from five individual
interpreters when we have our
international integral meetings when it
really is one dialect and it's absurd
you know that perhaps we should think
about standardized neck but this
solution is controversial many Inuit
worried that a standard Inuit language
would kill off local
Alex for good I see the positives and I
can see the negatives like it'll
strengthen literature and all that but
then when you look at Inuktitut and then
compared to a new in Upton then that
would wipe out any win Upton all
together and then there in our region as
well as not sealing mute and that's in
kigali region and Tala we are that would
be wiped out as well so taking them into
consideration we we can't wipe those out
because they're their languages to Edna
McLean is a linguist from Barrow Alaska
the local Inuit language there is called
anoop yok she's been advocating for a
common Inuit language writing system
since the 1970s there were no takers
then but with climate change and
globalization putting unprecedented
stress on Inuit culture today she says a
common language may just be the best
defense the environment is certainly
changing in the Arctic and much of our
culture is based on hunting it
especially with a focus towards the
marine mammals and their habitats being
able to walk out on the ice and not
having it too thin for you not to walk
on you know so it's up it's going to
affect our identification to the land to
the ocean so with that erosion then
there's an erosion of how you establish
identity I hope not but I think that a
lot of the hunting patterns are changing
and will continue to change so we need a
strong mental culture about language
music art and such Simon loose from
better known as maku is Greenland's most
prominent theatre director and producer
he supports the position of people like
Edna MacLean afraid for for you it's
because now after the climate think that
the big ships are going to sell through
northern part What's Wrong team in
alaska native Northwest past that's
responsible I'm afraid for that they
will kill our lifestyle so I think it's
very important that we should help this
like basic length before annuity even be
as a small people the way to the to make
exchange programs for for the language
or culture thing in this way we can so I
but getting people to agree on the need
for a common writing system or dialect
may just be half the battle after all
which dialect do you choose and who gets
to decide zacharias Canuck is a
filmmaker from Igloolik Nunavut he's won
awards around the world for his
ineptitude language films he says his
success proves Inuit culture can
flourish without a common dialect in my
line of work we do our inner clear audio
in even in feature films and when we set
it out to the world they just subtitle
it to Japanese Portuguese Spanish French
and English and where I'm at the same
playing field and I think care if we're
going to stand out promoting unique
culture what it is we should not be
looking to Alaska for help or to
Greenland for help we should do it
ourselves canuck says language experts
have a struggle ahead of them if they
want to standardize the Inuit language
in Canada let alone across the Arctic
and this is going to be hard like in
northern Quebec a leadership means happy
they're happy in my dialect erratic
mints you're scared you're spooked so
they're totally completely they are the
other way around and some of the words
are so yeah it's going to be a struggle
but despite people's concerns there is
one place in the Arctic where the Inuit
language has been standardized and has
been gaining strength ever since and
that's in Greenland a former Danish
colony and home to approximately 50,000
Inuit today here the language is called
kilala suit or Greenlandic in english
Greenlandic was standardized in the
1970s and now you see the language
everywhere you look though local
dialects are still spoken in the home
the standard language is what
greenlanders use to communicate with
each other magazines and newspapers are
published in greenlandic the graffiti is
in greenlandic and even heavy metal
punkin rap music are yes all sung in
greenlandic too many feel the greenland
example could be a model for what may
one day be possible across the Arctic
Peter Lewbert lives in Nuuk the capital
of Greenland by day he works at a local
daycare but by night he's known as P&L
one of Greenland's most successful
rappers he often tours in europe and
other areas of the Arctic he says he
can't imagine doing it in anything but
his own language
haha figured they will do now omikron
landok as a sink incrementing it's
representing the whole ancestor thing I
have in the background not just a rapper
not just a provocative controversial
rapper I'm taking kinetic on my home
back and carry it to like you know what
I just been learning answer them and
representing real any good or bad guy
did typical singing father you man I
knew all that there's so padgett cking
good see I respect my own language it's
a I can't imagine me rapping in
dancehall queen english because i feel
in love with the language screen lantic
and i will speak it everything anything
you did it die afterwards it go dr. were
in without Carl Christian Olsen better
known as poo you is a linguist and the
head of the Greenlandic language
secretariat that's the body that
authorizes new Greenlandic vocabulary
terminology and usage he says
standardizing the Inuit language means
greenlanders like P&O don't have to turn
to Danish or English to participate in
contemporary culture he says that keeps
young people wanting to speak the Inuit
language but in Greenland in Greenland
the way we look at our language is that
is part of our ethnicity part of our
culture but our language is not locking
our intellectual performance to the our
own culture no we are using our language
to to understand other cultures also
through our language you can read about
Harry Potter in green addict you can
read Steinbeck's in green on deck
the pivot taking for granted its way to
at the beginning of the writing form of
granitic the areas of cheating it is the
Bible and they're all stories but the
life is also what your way you are doing
right now so the life of the youth that
were the children is also have to be
accommodated by the segment's cultural
expressions in form of music from the
poetry in form of art and others are
helping also to support the survival of
the language no way that is enjoyable
follow us don't back in Canada Joe see
kooza gak says the greenland example is
proof of what standardization can do for
Inuit language and culture he hopes in
you it across the Arctic will make a
joint decision on language before it's
too late and I'm to a point now where I
used to shy away from making those kinds
of remarks and those kind of suggestions
but I'm old enough now I'm getting thick
skin to be able to say love pick a damn
toilet you know and will input every way
possible because we need to move on I
think the they'll develop a standard
Queens into the for Atlanta then there
are certain fundamentalist of inductive
language I won't will not be happy no
matter what you say so you have to
accept that I think but I think we're
talking about the survival of the
language and so the debate continues
but meanwhile back in iqaluit whatever
happened to Jeremy collecti after the
ill-fated rap concert tamazuki damn big
omaha do Pacifica dragon unless a bigot
as a piece of autonomy decade as you go
Sabine well at the end of the show P&L
asked the other rappers to come on stage
with him P&L freestyled in greenlandic
so did rapper Denali coed get gang so
the dead dude [ __ ] up doing it does
little finger soon enough then they
handed the mic to Jeremy and something
very special happened I was watching
when they wrap and I realized that he
was rapping in energy doe not England
that we map the party minimum is very
quick and he was riding but look at him
when he doing he take his cap off it has
lyrics and he rapping instead of instead
of off be there in the moment and
watching every everything in with the
ice I think he will be he'll be victim
someday because even though it's not
Morton to wrap in energy to he did and
he was confident and he was he was
shining through all of us and that that
that where I have goosebumps just to see
that the he's that he's in his own it
identity now not just like fake rebel
who wants to rap in English so I was
like yeah it was great but no one seemed
more surprised than Jeremy himself when
I tried to
during institute which it it went very
well but when asked us some of the
experience Jeremy prefers to let his
lyrics speak for themselves mcdermott
egg Miljkovic Jeremy me at the car too
mamita bunny baffin island me tiranga 60
mi ok hakuna i am i refer to say in your
passing in mine in a young officer up to
that could take another day mine is La
Mina imma go now peace ever getting my
mother's usama do get down p come back
I'm gonna take it there she goes to be
sure beans i'm doing the green number
through google god good the matter yet
many guys don't forgot i know we takin a
piece of it to the mommy time to do get
a new ship again